i want to ask you about your your health
i'm told you had eye surgery recently
yeah i like to do all the things i like
to have a global pandemic and also mix
in some eye surgery so yes i had eye
surgery
uh i have i've had bad eyes but i think
for the first time i have this thing
called good insurance
it's a guy look into it everybody she's
been waiting until you had good
insurance to get eye surgery yeah so
even the global pandemic could not stop
me from taking care of that of my eye
surgery so yeah
did it all go fine did it go did it go
well i mean right now i'm like an nba
player you see on the sidelines with
like the ice
like i'm gonna play the game but i'm a
little banged up so you can't even see
me right now
no i ca but your voice is so specific
it's clearly you it's clearly you it's
it's clearly
it's me or some i'm a blurry white lady
to you right there's a lot of white men
here but i'm like no that's conan right
yeah
i know i tend to stick out yeah yeah
your your woke whiteness is coming along
nicely we're all very proud of you in
the bay
i'm trying yeah you are which we
appreciate you know
i am known as the whitest man in america
uh so i i felt like this responsibility
yeah that's why me and my friend kate
shot to
she pulled you along we're like if we
can get him we can get everybody yeah
yeah and then you realize no most white
people don't like me
we didn't really do that you should have
looked into that first i didn't know the
show was going away
i thought he's gonna be on tv you wasted
yeah you reformed the wrong guy it was a
huge
you know i have to ask you about
something which is i you do a terrific
show
uh you do a fantastic show and then i
find out that you're
up against steve harvey for
two naacp image awards and i was
thinking to myself
you guys are doing such different things
really
yes you really are unless you're
starting to give away a lot of cash
on united shades i don't think so i mean
you're out there uh and you're you're
doing these
uh very uh you know probing and
thoughtful uh you know looks at
what's going on in america and racism
and then of course
uh steve harvey god bless him has family
feuds yeah which is i mean believe me
that's i wish i had that job
yeah that's the job you really want that
is the j i'm aiming for that job i
probably should have gone through
meeting with the clan to get there but
that's
i think it is funny that the guy who's
famous for meeting with the clan and the
guy who's favors for the big suits and
celebrity family flute
we're in the same category well have you
ever thought of if you really do like
that you could borrow a little from him
you know like you did that famous
episode where yeah
you went and you hung out with the clan
so maybe you do like a
game show yeah where you're with the
clan
you're trying to integrate them a little
and maybe that will change that well the
show is
basically america's greatest racism
every week we talk about the greatest
moments in america's racism but we don't
give away money we should start giving
away money
you know what you give away cars cash
prizes yeah
it's a whole other thing that's yeah
right before when i was nominated for
those two categories
uh i sent out a tweet that said i'm up
against steve harvey i look forward to
losing to him
and then i did lose to him yeah so yeah
i predicted it well i think the other
thing too
is you know that the quickest way to get
people
uh woke and maybe to get people uh aware
or racially sensitive is to say hey at
the other end of this
if you listen to me for 10 minutes
there's a possibility
you win a prius yes we should do that
that's how we should do that with a
vaccine if you get this vaccine you will
also get a prius
you know uh i can't believe because your
show
involves a lot of travel you're
traveling constantly through your show
and there's no way around that and then
you did it during covid
and i don't know first of all you
survived it congratulations
what was it like at the height of kovid
to be
flying uh you know to to to cover your
assignments well
let's be clear as a you know as a black
guy who's
in my 40s who has asthma and maybe some
high blood pressure
covert was looking for me like you know
i would leave places maybe like covered
was just here
yeah uh yes i got many times coveted
called me
i know you hang with kamau and i'm like
i
i can't tell you where he is he is on
the top of our list right
no yeah i was out there i felt like i
was dodging covert like neo in the
matrix
but uh yeah so we went out there massed
up shot everything outside
you know and like everybody was tested i
got tested every day and
you know there's and it's like rapid
tests there's like a half hour be like
is today the day
so yeah yeah so and what about airport
like describe
i have not been uh last week uh
i had to go up north to seattle
quickly uh uh there's something going on
with my wife's family
and so i had to rush up there and it was
i realized was the first time i'd been
on
this airplane in such a long time and in
an airport and things
felt like they're easing back to normal
yeah but you were in airports what were
they like at the height of the pentagon
i was out there it was like i am legend
like i was the one guy in the airport
with yeah like there was and you're like
the whole time you're like is this
really a good idea yeah all the stores
are sort of open but nobody's in them
just like take what you want leave some
money
it's fine right restaurants make what
you need we're not going to be here yet
i was out there getting on airplanes
sitting in your seat and you know air
travel is not the best anyway but air
travel during the pandemic they're just
sort of like this
they're just sort of tossing a bottle of
water towards you there's no yeah all
the luxury was gone yeah yeah
yeah but you got through it yeah i did
get i think you got through it and you
were able to do the work
yeah we did do the work we made seven
episodes of for this for this season
they cut one but we did we did we did
what we could do
and uh what about i know that you're a
hugger
no i am formally i i'm glad that's what
i'm going to say
former formerly a hugger yeah i have a
very tight hug circle now it's it's very
exclusive
uh i noticed you didn't hug me when i
saw you i said i have a very tight hug
circle now it's very exclusive
it's very plus i don't want to with my
eye i don't want to hug the wrong white
guy that's a whole thing
andy oh no andy did you get a hug from
kamau when you saw it
yeah no it's a very yeah you know what i
respect that you're discerning you know
i used to be like every everybody can
get a hug you know but now i
i am not doing that it's all it's all
the uh the elbow i do the elbow thing
now yeah yeah
and for years i used to do this on tv
and i found what do you do andy i do
this now sometimes to people
and it's just my way of saying i respect
you i acknowledge you
yes um i'm a buddhist i don't want you i
do the
i do the runaway you just run away when
i encounter people i just run the other
way
yeah you did that before long before
kovid
i'm scared i was raised by wolves